- How about the flirtiest?
Who's the flirtiest?
- Rita. (crowd gasps knowingly)
- I, I was gonna say
maybe either one of you.
I was gonna say, one
of you two are gonna...
- No, I mean, honestly, Rita
knows I'm going, oh my God.
Get the bag for this woman.
Like she, somebody, give her the hawk.
For goodness sake.
- No! live your life.
- Can I tell you a story about that?
- 100% please.
- Good.
One day.
- [Valerie] Oh, no.
- When Jane and I...
- [Valerie] Oh no!
- I can't wait.
- I love you, but shut up.
(crowd laughs)
So one day Jane and I
are sitting in the dark
waiting for a scene to get lit.
And it's just the two of us
and Jane, out of the blue says to me
how do you feel about sex?
And I immediately said, oh God
no, I'm done. Twee, ee, ew.
(everyone laughs)
And she said, okay. So about a week later
we were all going to do a
scene in the locker room.
And in the locker room are
these amazing, amazing people.
The guys, the guys in the movie.
And we all are starting to
make... we're entering the room.
This is not part of the, this
is not part of the scene.
This is just, we're entering the room.
And to my absolute, this is true.
Absolute ama... I have to stand up.
(crowd laughs)
- She needs the floor!
- She takes center stage.
- My absolute amazement.
I swear to God, swear to God
to my absolute amazement.
I take a deep breath
and I go (breathes in)
(crowd laughs)
- Look at you. (laughs)
- And then I said to myself,
pheromones
(crowd laughs)
- What'd she say?
- [Kelly] Pheromones.
- They do exist. Pheromones.
I'm talking to myself and saying,
oh my God what's the matter with you?
You're 90 for God's sake. You're 90.
- You're alive.
- And you know, I know now, I know...
- Does anyone know the
words to Moon River?
- There was a little ovary
saying, everybody up.
(claps hands)
(crowd cheers and claps)
That's a good story.
Its like a great story.
- Oh my God!
- And it's true.
There must have been, because
I mean what's suddenly...
♪ Moon river wider than a mile ♪
♪ Crossing you in style someday ♪
- Oh my God, I wish y'all
could stay here forever.